Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. We began in a perfect fever to strain our eyes for Rome. And when, after another mile or two, the eternal city appeared at length in the distance,
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要获取每周独家番外节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要获取番外节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。我们满怀狂热与期待，极目远眺罗马。当又前行了一两英里，那座永恒之城终于在远方显现时，
it looked like, I am half afraid to write the word, like London. That was Charles Dickens in his brilliant account of a travel across the continent, Pictures from Italy. And Dominic, maybe come back to Pictures from Italy because it's, well, it's so Dickensian, it's full of all his kind of comedy and energy. uh the tradition of british tourists going abroad and basically deciding that uh you know all these kind of wonderful places and cities um remind them of home is a noble tradition is it not um it is indeed i think willie morris will be doing that later in this episode right um so because this is the middle of aug the middle of August, it's the traditional time for people to go on holiday. We thought that we would do a series of episodes on the history of holidays. And in the first part, we were looking at the 18th century, the Grand Tour, much more aristocratic
它看起来——我甚至有点不敢写下这个词——看起来就像伦敦。这是查尔斯·狄更斯在他那部关于欧洲大陆旅行的精彩游记《意大利杂记》中写下的。多米尼克，也许我们可以回到《意大利杂记》，因为它，嗯，太具有狄更斯风格了，充满了各种各样的喜剧色彩和活力。嗯，英国游客出国旅游并基本上认为，你知道，所有这些美妙的地方和城市，嗯，都让他们想起家，这是一个崇高的传统，不是吗？嗯，确实如此。我想威利·莫里斯会在本集的后面部分谈到这点，对吧？嗯，因为现在是八月中旬，八月中旬是人们度假的传统时期。我们觉得可以做一系列关于假期历史的节目。在第一部分中，我们探讨了18世纪的“壮游”（Grand Tour），这是一种更加贵族化的
way of going on holiday, because basically you have to be incredibly rich and well-connected for it to be possible. But Dominic, we've come now to the 19th century and we ended yesterday's episode with Lord Byron going to Waterloo and musing in a kind of gloomy and profound way, putting it up into poetry, all that kind of stuff. But in fact, I mean, he was absolutely not the only person going to the battlefield of Waterloo was he uh not at all battlefield became a kind of one of the first great centers of tourism it was absolutely so um i think that the figure is that uh there are there are about 600 british visitors a day were arriving in in paris or in brussels they're sort of in the aftermath of the Battle of Waterloo. They're very excited to see all the bigwigs who are making the peace,
度假方式，因为基本上，你必须极其富有且人脉广阔才有可能成行。但多米尼克，我们现在来到了19世纪，我们在昨天的节目结尾时讲到拜伦勋爵去滑铁卢，以一种阴郁而深沉的方式沉思，把它写进诗里，诸如此类的事情。但事实上，我的意思是，他绝不是唯一一个去滑铁卢战场的人，对吧？哦，完全不是。战场成了最早的伟大旅游中心之一，确实如此。所以，嗯，我想数据是这样的：在滑铁卢战役结束后的一段时间里，大约每天有600名英国游客抵达巴黎或布鲁塞尔。他们非常兴奋地去见那些缔造和平的大人物，
but particularly keen to go and see the battlefield. So obviously they're going on boats. They go inevitably to Brussels and they have parties, just as people were doing before the battle itself happened. But then the extraordinary thing is, even as the battlefields are still littered with the sort of body parts of thousands upon thousands of British, Prussian, Frenchmen, you know, the flower of Europe,
但尤其热衷于去参观战场。所以很明显，他们坐船出行。他们不可避免地前往布鲁塞尔并举行派对，就像人们在战役发生前所做的那样。但随后非同寻常的是，甚至当战场上仍然散落着成千上万名英国人、普鲁士人、法国人——你知道，欧洲的精锐——的身体残骸时，
people are pouring over the battlefields for souvenirs. So the most famous example is Walter Scott. Walter Scott and his son, John, they go to the very farmhouse, which is called La Belle Alliance, where Wellington and Blucher had met in the sort of aftermath of Waterloo. And there are already people staying in this farmhouse straight away. Wow, I didn't know that. Yeah, they're just basically people that immediately want to go and stay there and walter scott buys uh some armor from a dead frenchman
人们依然蜂拥至战场搜寻纪念品。最著名的例子就是沃尔特·司各特。沃尔特·司各特和他的儿子约翰，他们去了那座名为“拉贝勒阿利安斯”（La Belle Alliance）的农舍，威灵顿和布吕歇尔就是在滑铁卢战役结束后在那里会面的。当时已经有人直接住进这座农舍里了。哇，我不知道这件事。是的，基本上就是有人立刻想去那里住。沃尔特·司各特买了一件从一个死去的法国士兵身上扒下来的盔甲，
so the people there are basically flogging the the body parts and the sort of relics it's not tourism is it but they're also flogging them to yorkshire farmers to use as fertilizer to use fertilizer yeah exactly I mean that's slightly the quest for fertilizer is it's a it's more industrial than than holiday based but yeah they they buy the Scots buy this um uh this armor which they take back to Abbotsford to their sort of to their sort of manorial seat um to exhibit and obviously people have done that actually ever since so when i was in um mostar in bosnia about 10 years ago there were stalls selling uh bullets may and shells that had been made into pen holders and things of that ilk yeah and that sort of ghoulishness
所以那里的人基本上是在兜售身体残骸和各种圣物。这根本算不上旅游吧？但他们甚至还把这些东西卖给约克郡的农民当化肥用，用来做化肥，对，没错。我的意思是，对化肥的追求，这其实比度假更偏向工业化。不过是的，他们，司各特父子买下了这套，嗯，这套盔甲，并把它带回了阿伯茨福德（Abbotsford）他们的庄园官邸里，用来展出。显然，人们从那以后实际上一直都在这么做。所以当大约10年前我在波斯尼亚的莫斯塔尔（Mostar）时，那里就有摊位在出售，嗯，由子弹壳和弹壳制成的小笔筒之类的小物件。是的，这种病态的猎奇心理，
i mean it's always been there so i mean we're jumping ahead a little bit but um during the boer war before the boer war was even over our travel agencies and we'll be talking about the birth of travel agencies in a little while they were advertising tours of the boer war battlefields while the war was still going on which just seems extraordinary well could we um could we just pull the camera back a bit so we we've talked about how the end of the Napoleonic Wars, suddenly it's like a kind of cork popping out of a but I was very relieved to read it by someone who really knows her stuff, which is Lucy Lethbridge, who has a brilliant book that's just come out called Tourists that I knew we were going to be doing this subject. And I saw a review of it in the Times and it was kind of effusive and went and rushed out, got it. And it's so good. And I know you've reviewed it for the Sunday Times. I've reviewed it myself, Tom.
我的意思是，它一直都存在。所以，虽然我们稍微有点跳跃，但是在布尔战争期间，甚至在布尔战争结束之前，旅行社——我们稍后会讨论旅行社的诞生——就已经在战争还在进行时打广告宣传布尔战争战场之旅了，这简直不可思议。好吧，我们能不能，嗯，把镜头稍微拉远一点？我们已经讨论了拿破仑战争的结束，突然间就像瓶塞被拔掉一样……不过我非常欣慰地读到了一位真正内行之人的著作，她就是露西·莱特布里奇（Lucy Lethbridge）。她刚出版了一本非常精彩的书叫《游客》（Tourists），当时我就知道我们要讲这个主题，并且我在《泰晤士报》上看到了对它的书评，评价非常热情，于是我立刻冲出去买了一本。这本书太棒了。我知道你为《星期日泰晤士报》写过书评。我自己也写过，汤姆。
I've reviewed it for the Sunday Times. I think it's an absolutely wonderful book because it's a look at the 19th and early 20th centuries and the invention of mass tourism. Basically, I guess you would argue by the British. And it covers everything from souvenirs and guidebooks to sort of travel agencies and sexual misbehaviour and holiday camps and the whole kind of panorama. It's a really, really fun read. Yeah, it's very funny often, but also kind of, you know, very compassionate, brings all kinds of
我为《星期日泰晤士报》写了书评。我认为这是一本绝对精彩的书，因为它审视了19世纪和20世纪初期大众旅游的诞生。基本上，我想你会认为是英国人开创了这一切。它涵盖了从纪念品、旅游指南到旅行社、不当性行为、度假营地以及整个全景式的画面。这是一本读起来非常非常有趣的书。是的，它通常非常滑稽，但也带有一种，你知道的，非常富有同情心的视角，把各种各样不同的旅行体验写得活灵活现。这是一本绝佳的书。所以露西·莱特布里奇的《游客》，极力推荐给大家。露西，如果你在听的话，我们要为接下来会有相当大一部分内容取材于你的精彩著作而道歉。好吧，这是一本好书。实际上，她提出的观点之一是，对于大多数人来说，在整个19世纪的大部分时间里，他们的闲暇时间实际上减少了。所以，（她举了英格兰银行假期的例子）。所以在1830年代，英格兰银行的假期实际上要少得多。所以这就是为什么后来有了银行假日。是的，银行假日。
different travel experiences alive. It's a fabulous book. So Lucy Lethbridge, tourists, can't recommend it highly enough. And Lucy, if you're listening, we apologize for the fact that an awful lot of what's going to follow derives from your wonderful book. Well, it's a great book. And actually, one of the points that she makes is that actually, for most people, their time off work actually declined for a lot of the 19th century. So, you know, she gives the example of Bank of England holidays. So there are actually far fewer Bank of England holidays in the 1830s. So that's why bank holidays. Yeah, bank holidays.
与一百年前相比确实如此。对于那些在规模庞大的工厂、造船厂、矿山等地工作的工人来说，他们是没有假期的。因此，我们谈论的贯穿大部分时间的假期——当然直到今天这集节目的后半部分之前——我想它们都是中产阶级假期。我的意思是，这就是它与壮游的区别：壮游是精英阶层的专属，而现在你有了这样一个白领中产阶级群体，他们渴望加入精英的行列。但是，多米尼克，我不想扯到宗教角度，但我还是要提，因为显而易见，假期（holiday）这个词本身就源于神圣的日子（holy day）。如果你是天主教徒，你会有大量的宗教节日。因此，工人们能够享有的宗教假期的缩减，其实是新教兴起的一个指标。我们在第一批节目中讨论过，第一批进行壮游的人基本上是去朝圣的天主教徒。那么你认为，英国对自身的这种看法——
And there had been 100 years earlier. And for people who are working in the massively expanding kind of factories and shipyards and mines and so on they don't get holidays so the holidays that we're talking about for a lot of this until certainly until the second half of this of today's episode they are there i guess they're middle class holidays i mean that's the difference with the grand tour the grand tour is the the elite and now you've got a middle a sort of white collar middle class who are aspiring to join them but But Dominic, I don't want to bring up the Christian angle, but I'm going to, because obviously a holiday is a holy day. And if you're Catholic, you have loads of holy days. So the kind of shrinkage of holy days that workers can have is an index of Protestantism. And we talked in the first episode about how basically the first grand tourists are Catholics going on pilgrimages. So do you think that that sense Britain has of itself
作为一个勤劳、崇尚新教、反天主教的国家，这其中是否存在某种微妙的紧张关系？我的意思是，也许他们正在试图重新发明轮子。因此，他们不得不发明假期的概念，因为天主教传统的假期概念已经消失了；他们不得不发明海外旅行的概念，因为朝圣的概念已经不复存在了。你觉得是这样吗？你觉得这里面有什么门道吗？这里面确实有些门道。我的意思是，我告诉你从哪里可以看出所谓的新教伦理。那就是认为度假对你有好处的观念。
as an industrious, Protestant, non-papist country, there is a kind of slight tension there. I mean, maybe they're trying to kind of reinvent the wheel a bit. So they're having to invent the idea of holidays because the traditional Catholic notion of a holiday has gone. They're having to invent the idea of foreign trips because the idea of pilgrimages has gone. Do you think that's, do you think there's anything in that? There's a bit in that. I mean, I think, I'll tell you where you might claim to see a sort of Protestant ethic. And that's the idea of holidays being good for you.
你知道，假期是……我们在“壮游”那一集里讨论过“壮游”的基础，以及认为去进行一次“壮游”具有某种道德意义的观点。是的。你知道，关于旅行开阔视野以及诸如此类我们都非常熟悉的想法。当然，还有一种观点认为它在字面意义上就是健康的。正如我们上次讨论的那样，去海滩并大量饮用海水可能会让你的身体变好。我认为这个观点也贯穿了今天的节目。即你的精神和身体健康可以通过度假得到改善。我认为这或许是人们不用感到内疚的一种方式，这也是人们游说
You know, holidays being, we talked in the Grand Tour episode about the foundations of the Grand Tour and the idea that it would be kind of ethical to go on a Grand Tour. Yeah. You know, the idea about travel broadening the mind and all that sort of thing that we're so familiar with. And also, of course, the idea that it is literally healthy. That, as we discussed last time, going to the beach and drinking loads of seawater might make you better. And I think that is woven through today's episode as well. The idea that your mental and physical health will be improved by going on holiday. And that's a way, I think, maybe for people not to feel guilty. And it's also a way for people to lobby
让男工女工也能享有假期的另一种方式，意思是：从长远来看，如果你给他们一周的假期，或者正如我们稍后会谈到的那样，给他们一个可以去海边度假的“Wakes周”（注：英国工业城市的传统假期），你将会拥有一支更健康、更高效的劳动力队伍。正如我一贯的习惯，再次回到宗教角度。在阅读露西·莱特布里奇的书之前，我没有意识到的一点是，旅游史上的许多伟大奠基人物实际上有着多么深厚的宗教信仰。其中最著名的当然是托马斯·库克（Thomas Cook），他是一名浸信会教徒。思想非常高尚，非常简朴，滴酒不沾。然而这样一个（你懂的），他看起来似乎是最不适合发明跟团游（package tour）的人，
for working men and women to get holidays too, to say, actually, in the long run, you'll have a more healthier and more productive workforce if you give them a week off, or if they get, as we'll talk about later, a wakes week where they can go to the seaside. Just returning, as is my wont, to the religious angle. One of the things that I had not appreciated until I read Lucy Lethbridge's book was just how deeply religious many of the great foundational figures in the history of tourism were. And the most famous of all, of course, is Thomas Cook, who was a Baptist. Very high-minded, very frugal, teetotal. And yet this, you know, he seems the most unsuitable person basically to have invented the package tour,
而这正是他所做的事情。是的，这基本上就是他在做的事，没错。我从露西的书里了解到，跟团游发明于1841年，当时莱斯特有500人想要去拉夫堡参加一个戒酒集会。太精彩了。
which is what he does. Yeah, which is basically what he's doing, exactly. And the package tour is invented, I learned from Lucy's book, in 1841 when 500 people in Leicester want to go to Loughborough to attend a temperance meeting. It's so brilliant.
贝尼多姆和牙医诊所就是这样诞生的。这就是那棵盛产放荡和醉酒的参天大树所长出的小小橡树果。这是一个极其滑稽并置，不是吗？每一个在马加鲁夫（Magaluf）的俱乐部里喝得酩酊大醉的人，都要归功于1840年代的戒酒运动。当时他们都需要从莱斯特赶往拉夫堡。于是库克做的事就是批量预订火车票——火车使这一切成为可能——因此他得到了折扣。他们到达了那里，
That is how Benidorm and the dentist's chair. And this is the kind of little acorn from which that mighty oak of debauchery and drunkenness will come. It's a hilarious juxtaposition, isn't it? That everybody who's getting wasted in a club in Magaluf owes it to the temperance movement of the 1840s. And so they all have to get from Leicester to Loughborough. And so what Cook does is he mass books train tickets. So trains have made this possible. And so he gets a discount. And they go there and they arrive.
一切都很顺利。整个活动取得了巨大成功。库克发出了一声欢呼：“为禁酒主义和铁路主义再多欢呼一声！”所以我希望，当我今年夏天去度假时，我一定会发出这样的欢呼。我甚至能在伊比沙岛的俱乐部里看到你了，汤姆。你成了狂欢者的领头羊。“为禁酒主义和铁路主义再多欢呼一声！”我的意思是，我觉得，
And it's great. The whole occasion is a great success. And Cook raises this cheer. One cheer more for teetotalism and railwayism. So I hope that, which I shall certainly be raising when I go on my holidays this summer. I get to see you in the clubs of Ibiza now, Tom. You're leading, leading the revelers. One cheer more for teetotalism and railwayism i mean i think it's
它已经忘却了最初的根源，但是，那确实是……所以托马斯·库克，我的意思是，他是一个非常严肃的人，对吧？他绝对是一个极其典型的维多利亚时代人物，就像那些巧克力工业背后的贵格会教徒一样，等等。是的。他如你所说，是来自德比郡的浸信会教徒，他的妻子是一名主日学校老师。他曾做过木工车床工，但也担任过某种前福音派传教士。他萌生了戒酒运动的想法——你知道，这种戒酒旅游，你会乘火车去参加戒酒集会。我想，真正让他的名字名声大噪的另一件事，是带人们去参观伦敦世界博览会。所以世界博览会是10年后的1851年，他基本上为65,000人预订了车票，
it's it's it's forgotten its roots in that but but that is um you know so thomas cook is i mean he's a very earnest man isn't he he is um he's he's an absolutely classic sort of victorian like the sort of you know the quakers behind the chocolate industry and so on yeah um he was as you say he's a baptist from derbyshire uh his wife is a sunday school teacher he works as a wood turner but also as a kind of pre-evangelical preacher and he has this idea of temperance you know of this sort of temperance tourism that you'll you'll get the trains temperance meetings and i guess the other thing that really makes his name is the taking people to the great exhibition so the great exhibition is is 10 years later 1851 and he basically books tickets for 65 000 people
让他们去伦敦。他们到达那里后，还包办了住宿，所以他们可以住在某种戒酒酒店里，并且能拿到世博会的入场券。你完全可以理解，嗯，两件事。第一，这在铁路诞生之前几乎是不可能的。是的，所以为铁路主义欢呼！为铁路主义欢呼，没错。但其中也有一种自我提升的理念，即你将得以一睹国家的首都，
to go down to london um and they get there so they get they get their accommodation as well so they get to stay in kind of temperance hotels and they get their entry tickets to the exhibition. And you can completely see how, well, two things. One, this is impossible pretty much before the birth of the railways. Yeah, so hooray for railwayism. Hooray for railwayism, exactly. But also there is a kind of improving idea to it, that you will get to see the nation's capital,
你将得以一睹国家的首都，你将得以一睹世博会以及工业新教资本主义为你带来的奇迹。你也可以理解为什么，即使在此时，竞争对手也已经出现了。比如稍后有一位名叫亨利·盖斯（Henry Gaze）的人，他也组织铁路旅行。我不确定他是否具有同等程度的……而且他实际上是一位公理会教徒。所以可能同样有着那种禁酒的热情。基督教是一切的核心，汤姆。嗯，当然，当1855年——也就是世博会四年后——
you will get to see the nation's capital, you will get to see the great exhibition and the marvels that industrial Protestant capitalism has brought you. And you can sort of also see why, you know, even at this point, there are rivals. So there's a guy a little bit later called Henry Gaze, who organizes railroad trips. I'm not sure whether there's the same degree of him. And he's a congregationalist, actually. So there probably is the same degree of temperance, enthusiasm. Christianity at the heart of everything, Tom. Well, and of course, then tensions start to arise when in 1855, so that's what, four years after Great Exhibition,
第一次组织前往巴黎的海外旅行时，紧张局势便开始显现。巴黎当然是天主教、不良行为以及普遍的不道德行为的温床。即使在库克开始组织前往意大利和西班牙——那些天主教迷信的绝对粪坑——的旅行时，他仍然向坚定的新教徒发出警告，不是吗？警告他们提防神甫和迷信以及诸如此类的事情。但他仍然为戒酒者和浸信会教徒提供折扣。有趣的是，显然，就像我们现在完全……好吧，我想人们有时在国外参观教堂或类似地方时确实会行为不端，
the first foreign trip is organized to Paris. And Paris, of course, is a hotbed of uh catholicism and bad behavior and bad behavior generally um and cook even once he starts organizing trips to italy and spain and you know absolute sinks of papery um he is having i mean he kind of issues warnings to stout protestants doesn't he um warning them to watch out for priests and superstition and all this kind of stuff. And he's still offering discounts to teetotalers and Baptists. Well, the funny thing is that actually, clearly, in a way that we now have completely, well, I suppose people do behave badly, don't they, in churches and things,
比如穿着不合适的衣服之类的。但有一些惊人的故事：人们去罗马的圣彼得大教堂，在弥撒期间野餐。看到这个了吗？他们带着野餐篮子在弥撒期间走进圣彼得大教堂，
sometimes when they go abroad, they wear inappropriate clothes or whatever. But there is amazing stories about people going to St. Peter's in Rome and having picnics during mass. See this? They have, they take picnic hampers into St. Peter's during mass
然后喝香槟。因为，我不……想必他们只是觉得，哦，这全都是迷信的垃圾。你知道，
and they have champagne and they, because, and I don't, and presumably this is, they just think, oh, this is all superstitious rubbish. You know,
谁在乎呢？我们野餐吧。是的，所以这可不像伊恩·佩斯利（Ian Paisley，坚定的北爱新教激进派神职人员）去度假，对吧？他们只是觉得，哦，这全都是迷信的垃圾。你知道，谁在乎呢？我们野餐吧。是的，所以这可不像伊恩·佩斯利去度假，对吧？我的意思是，他们不是在做那种……或者你觉得他们是在以此表明他们对天主教骄傲的新教蔑视？你觉得他们会这么做吗？好吧，他们在国内可不会这么做，对吧？我不知道。
who cares? Let's have a picnic. Yeah, so it's not like Ian Paisley going on holiday, is it? I mean, they just think, oh, this is all superstitious rubbish. You know, who cares? Let's have a picnic. Yeah, so it's not like Ian Paisley going on holiday, is it? I mean, he's not, they're not kind of doing it. Or do you think they are making a statement of their proud Protestant contempt for it? Do you think they would do it? Well, they wouldn't do it at home, would they? I don't know.
我的意思是，他们只是觉得这没什么吗？我不知道。我想他们只是觉得……这是任何曾作为团体一部分去度假的人都会有的那种奇妙体验——比如单身汉派对（stag party）或你当然参加过的体育巡回赛，汤姆，那就是典型的例子。我去过圣彼得大教堂进行体育巡回赛。你看！我们在梵蒂冈踢过球。你在梵蒂冈打过板球，对吧？是的，我们在圣彼得广场打过板球，而且我们必须在被警察阻止之前赶紧把它打完。所以是的，这非常相似。如果意大利人做这个播客，他们可能会对你的板球巡回赛讲出不同的故事，他们可能会以完全不同的眼光看待它。
I mean, do they just think it's all right? I don't know. I think they just think, I think it's that curious thing that anyone who's ever been on holiday as part of a group so the sort of stag party or the sports tour tom which you of course do is the is the classic example of that i've been on a sports tour to saint peter's there you go we played the vatican you played cricket in the vatican didn't you yeah we played we played cricket in saint peter's square uh and we had to do it very quickly before we got stopped by the police so yes it's very similar the italians if they were doing this podcast might tell a different story about your cricket tour they might see it in a very different light yeah they might say this is actually worse
是的，他们可能会说这比那些大喝香槟的野餐者行为还要糟糕。但事实并非如此，因为我们随后去见了教皇，所以他显然原谅了我们。是的，那并没有发生。但你看，那是……在播客中，我们谈到了博斯韦尔（Boswell），詹姆斯·博斯韦尔（James Boswell）与卢梭和伏尔泰会面。我问你是否做过类似的事情。而我，当然是去见了保加利亚足协的邦乔·托多罗夫（Boncho Todorov）。你说你没做过那种事，
behavior than the champagne quaffing picnickers but it was but i don't think so because we then went on we met the pope so he'd obviously forgiven us yeah that didn't happen but you see that was well that's your you know in the podcast, we were talking about Boswell, James Boswell meeting Rousseau and Voltaire. And I asked you if you had ever done anything like that. Me, of course, meeting Boncho Todorov from the Bulgarian Football Union. And you said you hadn't done that,
但你其实做过，因为你见到了教皇。是的，但当我说是去见教皇时，当时大概还有大约4,000人也去见了他。大家都在圣彼得广场。我的意思是，那不是那种“哦，你好，教皇陛下”式的会面。不，那不是一场板球观众式的接见。
but you did because you met the Pope. Yeah, but when I say meet the Pope, there were about kind of 4,000 people who were meeting him as well. It was all in St. Peter's Square. I mean, it wasn't a kind of, oh, hello, your holiness. No. It wasn't a cricketing audience.
不，只有我们两个人——塞巴斯蒂安·福克斯（Sebastian Faulks）、彼得·弗兰科潘（Peter Frankopan）——得到了接见。他们是贵族老爷，而我们都是那些不得不留在后面的卑微随从。是的，我们在背景里潜伏着。汤姆，这真是一场悲剧，
No, only two of us, Sebastian Foulkes, Peter Frankopan, they got to meet him. So they were the millords and we were all the kind of humble retainers who had to stay behind. Yeah, we lurked in the background. Tom, that's such a tragedy
因为你，偏偏是你，我的意思是，你会有那么多的话题可以聊。你可以向他讲述你的书以及诸如此类的事情。恐怕这就是……悲剧的写照，折射出了那种令人反感的阶级结构，确实如此。说到令人反感的阶级结构，显然存在着大量的势利眼，
because you, of all people, I mean, you'd have had so much to talk about. You could have told him about your book and all that sort of thing. I'm afraid that's the tragedy because you of all people i mean you'd have had so much to talk about you could have told him about your you know your book and all that sort of thing i'm afraid that's the kind of reflection of the invidious class structures that it is well talking of invidious class structures so there's obviously an enormous amount of snobbery um from the sort of the i suppose the grand tour class towards the people who are going on the cooks tours and this is the point at which you start to see people using words like, they say there's a horde, there are swarms, there are a mob of tourists,
来自壮游阶层对那些参加库克旅行团的人的势利。正是在这个时候，你开始看到人们使用这样的词汇：他们说有一群、有一大群、有一帮游客，
they don't know how to behave, they don't know, you know, people are mocking the sort of the people who take up. People talk about cook's circus, I think. And that sort of sense of holidays becoming something that are absolutely freighted with kind of social stratification, social prejudice. I think you get that from the mid 19th century. Isn't that also, so going on the Grand Tour, you're supposed to already know everything. You're supposed to know your Latin and your Greek and your classical antiquities and all that kind of thing. But if you don't have that absolute kind of background in it,
他们不知道如何举止，他们不知道（你知道的），人们在嘲笑那些参加旅行团的人。人们谈论“库克的马戏团”，我想是的。那种认为假期充满了社会分层和阶级偏见的意识，我认为从19世纪中期开始就能感受到了。难道这也是……所以去参加壮游，你本该已经无所不知。你本该懂得拉丁语、希腊语、古典古董以及所有这些东西。但如果你没有那种绝对的背景知识，
then you're going to need advice, aren't you? And I loved learning from Lucy Lethbridge's book that the publisher of what is widely thought to be the first guidebook was also the publisher of Byron, John Murray. So John Murray, who published Childe Harold's Pilgrimage, is a great poetic account of, you know, a doomed romantic figure crossing a Europe of ruins and romantic bandits is also, you know, John Murray is also publishing what she called Mariana Stark, which was published in 1820 travels on the continent. I love her list of what you need so you need pillows blankets
那么你就会需要建议，对吧？我很高兴从露西·莱特布里奇的书里得知，被广泛认为第一本旅游指南的出版商，同时也是拜伦的出版商——约翰·穆雷（John Murray）。所以出版了《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》（Childe Harold's Pilgrimage）的约翰·穆雷——这是一首伟大的诗意叙事，讲述了一个注定失败的浪漫主义人物穿梭于一片废墟和浪漫主义强盗的欧洲——同时也在出版她所说的玛丽安娜·斯塔克（Mariana Stark）于1820年出版的《大陆旅行指南》。我喜欢她列出的物品清单：你需要枕头、毯子、
pillowcases mosquito nets towels tablecloth napkins traveling chamberlock pistols pocket knives carving knife and fork a silver teapot ink powder pens razors straps and hones needles thread tape worsted and pins a, a medicine chest with scales, weights, an ounce and half ounce, measures for liquids, a glass, pestle and mortar, tooth and hairbrushes. And I could go on because the paragraph is enormous. When I was writing my most recent history
枕套、蚊帐、毛巾、桌布、餐巾、旅行便携锁、手枪、折叠刀、雕刻刀叉、银茶壶、墨水粉、钢笔、剃须刀、皮条和磨刀石、针、线、带子、粗纺呢绒和大头针、一个带天平、砝码（一盎司和半盎司）、液体量杯、玻璃研钵和研杵、牙刷和发刷的药箱。而且我可以继续念下去，因为这段文字太长了。当我正在写我最近关于战后英国的历史著作——
of post-war Britain, so it's about the early 1980s, I kicked off by looking at American guidebooks and what they said about Britain. You know, the sort of Fodor's guide and the Let's Go guide to Britain in 1980, 81. And they're hilarious. And I think guidebooks and what they said about Britain, you know, the sort of Fodor's guide and the Let's Go guide to Britain in 1980, 81. And they're hilarious. And I think guidebooks and phrasebooks are often fantastic, this first guidebook, that she understood that the underlying default position, even of the open-minded tourist, was of suspicion and
也就是关于1980年代初期的那一本——我一开始查阅了美国的旅游指南，看看它们是怎么评价英国的。你知道，1980、81年左右的《福多尔指南》（Fodor's guide）和《出发指南》（Let's Go guide）英国卷。它们太滑稽了。我认为旅游指南和短语手册往往非常棒……这本第一本旅游指南，她明白，即使是思想开放的游客，其内心深处的默认心态也是怀疑和恐惧。
fearfulness. Stark told her readers their fears were understandable, and then brusquely how they might overcome them. Have you seen the phrase books? So there's a phrase book, an English Italian phrase book from 1828. And at the top of the list of useful phrases, he has hurt, he bleeds. Do not weep, it will soon be cured, but it is a scratch. But also, I am ruined, I shall be scalded. Poor little creature that I am, where can I hide myself? She also cites one from 1874, which I thought had the best of the lot. The carriage is near the precipice.
斯塔克告诉她的读者，他们的恐惧是可以理解的，然后生硬地告诉他们如何克服这些恐惧。你见过那些短语手册吗？有一本1828年的英意短语手册，在实用短语列表的顶端，有这样几句：“他受伤了，他在流泪。不要哭，很快就会治愈的，但这只是个擦伤。”还有：“我破产了，我会被烫伤的。我这个可怜的小家伙，我能躲到哪里去呢？”她还引用了一本1874年的短语手册，我认为这是其中最棒的一本：“马车靠近悬崖了。
One of the wheels is off. The axle tree is broken, which is very Italian. That hasn't changed because this is one from the 1960s, the Let's phrase book. So if you're traveling to Italy, these are the phrases. Look out. Be quiet. Leave me alone. I should call a policeman.
其中一个车轮掉了。车轴断了。”这非常意大利。这一点一直没变，因为这是一本1960年代的《出发》短语手册。所以如果你去意大利旅行，这些是你要用到的短语：“小心。安静。别管我。我该叫警察了。
I urgently need an ironmonger. Well, unchangeable. When would you require that final phrase? I should call a policeman. I urgently need an ironmonger. Well, unchangeable. Where would you require that final phrase? Anyway, so yeah, you need the guidebook. You're obviously suspicious of the food is another thing. So you don't really hear a lot of that from the Grand Tourist, but you start to hear that a lot in the 19th century.
我急需一个五金匠。”真是亘古不变。什么时候才会用到最后那个短语呢？“我该叫警察了。我急需一个五金匠。”真是亘古不变。你在什么情况下会需要最后那个短语？不管怎样，是的，你需要旅游指南。显然对食物的怀疑是另一回事。在壮游者的游记里你听不到太多这种抱怨，但你在19世纪开始频繁听到这种声音，
And of course, later on with packaged tourism in the 20th century. So you get all these people who talk about the sort of greasy ragus that they're being given in Italy and people who say they're only going to subsist on boiled eggs or something. I mean, that's a very kind of 1960s British attitude. But that's there right from the beginning, isn't it? It is. And it was also in travelogues that you get the first mentions of pizza so people going to we talked in the last episode about people going to um to naples to naples yeah so 1843 a travelogue describes a pizza as a sort of cake made from flour lard eggs and garlic and then its next mention is in the gourmet's guide to europe 1903 lieutenant colonel nathaniel
当然，在20世纪的跟团旅游中更是如此。所以你会听到所有人都在谈论意大利给他们的那种油腻的菜酱（ragù），还有人说他们只靠水煮蛋之类的东西维生。我的意思是，这是一种非常典型的1960年代英国人态度。但这种态度从一开始就存在，不是吗？确实如此。而且也是在游记中，你第一次听到了关于“披萨”的记载。人们去往——我们在上一集里讨论过人们去那不勒斯，
noonan davis he sounds like a spandered fellow is he a fan do you know what he calls a pizza The Gourmet's Guide to Europe, 1903. Lieutenant Colonel Nathaniel Newnham Davis. He sounds like a spattered fellow. Is he a fan? Do you know what he calls a pizza? He says it's like a kind of Yorkshire pudding. He does sound a tremendous chap. Eaten either with cheese or with anchovies and tomatoes, which is true because he's basically describing either pizza margarita
那不勒斯，是的——所以1843年的一篇游记将披萨描述为一种由面粉、猪油、鸡蛋和大蒜制成的蛋糕。而它的下一次被提及是在1903年的《欧洲美食指南》（The Gourmet's Guide to Europe）中，作者是中校纳撒尼尔·纽纳姆·戴维斯（Lieutenant Colonel Nathaniel Newnham Davis）。他听起来像个衣冠楚楚的家伙，是个狂热分子吗？你知道他是怎么称呼披萨的吗？
or a marinara, two great neapolitan pizzas but a yorkshire i mean how else would you quite tempted to do that the yorkshire pudding with anchovies oh no there was a brilliant pub in cambridge actually in the 1990s that did uh yorkshire puddings with chili stuffed with chili giant yorkshire pudding stuffed with chili con carne anyway this is not sure about that this is is a massive tangent dominic i think we should have a a break fairly soon but before we do that because we i know that you want to go on to talk about spars so we talked about bath didn't we in the first episode but um we did it turns out that german spars are a kind of different league but before we do that can i just could i just return to dickens's pictures from Italy and give you a breakdown of what he describes?
他说它就像一种约克郡布丁。他听起来确实是个了不起的家伙。配着奶酪或者凤尾鱼和西红柿吃，这倒没错，因为他基本上是在描述玛格丽特披萨（Pizza Margherita）或大蒜凤尾鱼披萨（Marinara），这两种绝妙的那不勒斯披萨。但是约克郡布丁——我的意思是，怎么会有人……我很想试试那个：加凤尾鱼的约克郡布丁。哦，不，剑桥有一家很棒的酒吧，在1990年代，他们做过加入辣椒的约克郡布丁，塞满了辣椒肉酱（chili con carne）。不管怎样，这扯得太远了，多米尼克，我觉得我们应该很快休息一下。但在那之前——因为我知道你接下来想谈谈温泉疗养地，我们在第一集里讨论过巴斯（Bath），不是吗？——但我们发现，德国的温泉完全是另一个级别。不过在此之前，我能回到狄更斯的《意大利杂记》，给你讲讲他所描述的见闻吗？
Yes. Okay. So he goes to Avignon and he visits the rooms in which the Inquisition used to operate. And Dickens gets a guide who had a mysterious hag-like way with her forefinger when approaching the remains of some new horror, looking back and walking stealthily and making horrible grimaces. So that's a very popular thing isn't it still it's going to see sites of torture suffering all that kind of thing i love that when i go on holiday yeah well dickens actually goes he sees a guillotining um so when he gets when he gets to rome um he actually watches it and he's clearly absolutely fascinated by it. He goes to Leghorn, which is what the British called Livorno. Not many years ago, there was an assassination club there, the members of which bore no ill will to anybody in particular, but stabbed people,
好的。所以他去了阿维尼翁，参观了宗教裁判所过去运作的房间。狄更斯找了一个导游，当接近某种新恐怖遗迹时，导游用食指做出了某种神秘的巫婆般的手势，回头窥视，蹑手蹑脚地走路，还做出可怕的鬼脸。所以这仍然是一个非常受欢迎的景点，不是吗？就是去看酷刑、苦难以及诸如此类的遗址。我度假时很喜欢看这些。是的，狄更斯甚至亲自去看了断头台的行刑。当他到达罗马时，他实际上观看了行刑，并且显然对此着迷不已。他去了里窝那（Leghorn），英国人就是这么叫利沃诺（Livorno）的。“就在数年前，那里曾有一个刺杀俱乐部，其成员对任何特定的人都没有恶意，但为了娱乐和刺激，他们会在夜里的大街上随机刺杀完全陌生的人。”所以那会很有趣。那，你知道的……
quite strangers to them, in the streets at night for the pleasure and excitement of the recreation. So that'd be fun. That's, you know. Well, yeah, but you don't join if you're a tourist, do you? I mean, you just have to live in be fun that's you know well yeah but you don't join if you're a tourist do you i mean you just have to live in fear of that i mean clearly dickens quite fancy yeah but it's um there's a kind of there's a passage he gets to piacenza and he writes sitting on this hillock where a bastion used to be and where a noisy fortress was in the time of the old roman station here i became aware that i have never known till now what it is to be lazy.
好吧，是的，但如果你是个游客，你可不会加入，对吧？我的意思是，你只需要生活在……会很有趣，那是……好吧，是的，但如果你是个游客，你可不会加入，对吧？我的意思是，你只需要生活在对这种事的恐惧中。我的意思是，狄更斯显然挺想……但这是一个段落：他来到了皮亚琴察（Piacenza），他写道：“坐在曾经是堡垒、在老罗马驻军时代曾是一座喧闹要塞的小丘上，我意识到，直到此刻我才真正懂得什么是懒惰。”
Because Dickens is famously, I mean, he's not a man who's ever lazy. But it's so typical of him that he's feeling lazy. He has to get out his notebook and write it down. That is very Dickensian. But it's also quite a Taurus thing, isn't it? That in a way, I mean, it's kind of Instagram. You can't enjoy a beautiful view
因为狄更斯是出了名的……我的意思是，他绝不是一个会偷懒的人。但这就非常符合他的风格：当他感到自己懒惰时，他必须掏出笔记本把它写下来。这非常狄更斯。但这也是一种非常“游客”的行为，不是吗？从某种意义上说，这就像是 Instagram 的雏形。除非你拍下一张照片并把它发到网上，
unless you've taken a photograph of it and posted it. Yeah. It's not real unless you've documented it. It's not real unless you've written a postcard, as was, or now you've photographed it, Instagrammed it, whatever. And it's absolutely typical of Dickens that the day after he has discovered what it is to be lazy, he's off again. It's such a delight to me to leave new scenes behind and still go on encountering newer scenes. And that, again, is absolutely part of the tourist experience to this day for going on a tour around.
否则你根本无法享受美景。除非你把见闻记录下来，否则它就不是真实的。除非你写了明信片（按当时的习惯），或者现在你给它拍了照、发了 Instagram 等等，否则它就不是真实的。这绝对是狄更斯的典型作风：在他发现什么是懒惰的第二天，他又出发了。“把新的风景抛在身后，继续去遭遇更新的风景，这对我来说真是一大乐事。”而这，同样是至今仍在环球旅行的游客体验中不可或缺的一部分。
I mean, the stereotype is the American or the Japanese tourists, isn't it, for Europeans that they turn up in today's. If it's Monday, it must be Paris. Yeah. So Dickens is kind of blazing a path there. He is indeed. That people will follow. You can never have yeah so Dickens is kind of blazing a path there he is indeed that people will follow you can never have too much Dickens
我的意思是，对于欧洲人来说，典型的刻板印象就是美国游客或日本游客，不是吗？他们会在今天出现在这里：“如果今天是星期一，那一定是在巴黎。”所以狄更斯可以说是开创了先河。他确实如此。人们会效仿。你永远不会……是的，所以狄更斯可以说是开创了先河，人们会效仿。你永远不会嫌狄更斯太多。
we will leave you with that and when we come back we will go to German spas let us plunge into those murky waters after the break Tom
我们就用这句话留作悬念，等我们回来后，将前往德国的温泉疗养地。中场休息后，让我们一起潜入那些浑浊的水域吧，汤姆。
see you in a minute I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、影评以及一点点秀场八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are on holiday, specifically we are on holiday in the Victorian period. And Dominic, we are heading off to Germany, aren't we, to enjoy the waters? Yeah, so in the last episode, Tom, we talked about the Grand Tour. The list of destinations that people went to, there were some of the very familiar big names from today, so France, Italy, but there are also some that are perhaps a tiny bit more unfamiliar. Not that many people go to Switzerland anymore for their summer holiday. And British tourists are notoriously reluctant to go to Germany on holiday, which is actually a huge break with tradition and with history.
如果你想要无广告收听、番外节目以及抢先购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。哈喽，欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。我们在度假，具体来说，我们在维多利亚时代的假期里。多米尼克，我们要前往德国去享受温泉了，对吧？是的，在上一集里，汤姆，我们讨论了“壮游”。人们当时去目的地清单中，有一些是今天我们非常熟悉的知名大城市，比如法国、意大利，但也有一些可能稍微陌生一点。现在没多少人会去瑞士过暑假了。英国游客出了名地不愿意去德国度假，这其实与传统和历史形成了巨大的断裂。
Because in the 18th and 19th centuries, Germany was a colossally popular destination for British holidaymakers. And you went to Germany for the same reason that you would have gone to Bath or to Brighton in the 18th century. So you go there partly for the social scene but also you go because of your your health so spa tourism is a massive industry in the 19th century and you were talking before the break about Lucy Lethbridge's book tourists brilliant brilliant book which I heartily recommend to all our listeners and she has the most wonderful chapter in that book about um the popularity of all these awful sounding German spa towns. So there's a bloke, so a bloke in 1844 writes a book called Quacks and Quackery. And he says, a gang of crafty adventurers thrive richly upon English credulity and chuckle in
因为在18和19世纪，德国是英国度假者极其热门的目的地。你去德国的原因和你在18和19世纪去巴斯（Bath）或布赖顿（Brighton）的原因是一样的。你一部分是为了那里的社交场景而去，但你也是为了健康而去。因此，温泉旅游（spa tourism）是19世纪的一个庞大产业。你在中场休息前谈到了露西·莱特布里奇那本精彩绝伦的书——《游客》，我由衷地向所有听众推荐这本书。她在书中有一个极其精彩的章节，讲的是所有这些听起来糟糕透顶的德国温泉小镇的受欢迎程度。有一个家伙，在1844年写了一本书叫《江湖郎中与庸医骗术》（Quacks and Quackery）。他说：“一帮狡猾的冒险家靠着英国人的轻信而大发横财，为英国人的愚蠢暗自窃笑。”他基本上是在谈论法国和德国境内数百个带有大量医生的温泉疗养地。所以我想今天人们去温泉时，是没有医生在场的，对吧？我的意思是，你不会进行某种医疗咨询。没有，我从没去过。你去过温泉吗？没有。
their sleeve at English stupidity. And what he's basically talking about are all these hundreds of spas across France and Germany which come with huge numbers of doctors. So I guess when people go to a spa today, there's not a doctor present, is there? I mean, you don't have a kind of medical consultation. No, I've never been. Have you ever been to a spa? No.
不，我从没去过温泉。你在那儿都干嘛？你是去喝热水的吗？不，我只是像一头搁浅的鲸鱼一样躺在他们的泳池里。嗯，你知道，我妻子会接受各种各样的理疗……我以为你得喝热水呢。不，我不是说去那种德国温泉疗养地，我是说去一些高档酒店。你不能突然转换概念，我刚才想的不是那种温泉，我指的是那些有健身药球（medicine balls）的德国温泉。
No, I've never been to a spa. What do you do? Do you kind of drink hot water? No, I just lie in the i just lie like a beached whale in their pool um well you know my wife has treatments of various kinds you know i thought you had to drink hot water no not i'm not talking about going to like a german star spa i'm talking about going to some fancy hotel you can't suddenly switch gears and i wasn't thinking about those kind of spas i was was thinking about the German ones with medicine balls.
不，不，不。显然，我绝不会靠近那种地方方圆一百英里以内。治疗肥胖的疗法。好吧，你知道露西·莱特布里奇对德国温泉是怎么说的吗？对于每一种想象得到的病痛，都有量身定制的疗法，一旁驻守的医生声称自己精通各种专科。有骨科医生、寄生虫（虫类）医生、风湿病和水疗医生。提供的疗法包括放射性泥浆、发汗石窟（sweat grottos）、
No, no, no. Obviously, I would never go within 100 miles of such a place. Cures for corpulence. Well, you know what Lucy Lethbridge says about the German spas. There were bespoke treatments for every conceivable affliction with physicians on hand claiming every specialism. There were bone doctors, worm doctors, wind and water doctors. Treatments on offer included radioactive mud, sweat grottos,
喷雾疗法（sal de pulverisation）、气体注射和打击式水疗（percussion douches）。你从来没有渴望过一次打击式水疗吗？什么是气体注射？我的意思是……好吧，我不知道，我想他们会把气体注射进你的眼睛、耳朵和其他孔道里。他们总不能把气体注射进你的静脉吧？我的意思是，那肯定不健康。他们会……这里来了，我正在读露西·莱特布里奇的书：“在波西米亚的马林巴德（Mariánské Lázně）等许多温泉疗养地，都有气体浴，病人
sal de pulverisation, gas injections, and percussion douches. Have you never craved for a percussion douche? What is a gas inject? I mean. Well, I don't know i think they would i think they would put gas into into your eyes ears and other orifices they can't be injecting gas into your veins i mean i can't be healthy they would here we go uh i'm reading from lucy lethbridge's book and many spas including marion bad and bohemia there were gas baths while the patient
坐在一个封闭的浴缸里，温暖或寒冷的气体从底部通过管道输送进来。甚至有一两个地方设有专门针对眼睛和耳朵的气体浴，通过一个小羽毛管将气体注射进去。”你会喜欢这个吗？不。所以他们会把你埋在沙子里——这是另一个大项目——然后他们有这种公共浴池。她对这些浴池的评价是：它们绝对恶心。人们把它们比作“热辣鸡汤”（mulligatawny soup），因为温泉水无论如何都带有一种奇怪的颜色，而且显而易见，你还要和一大堆德国人、一大堆……我的意思是，还有英国游客一起共享。而且你还要喝温泉水——也就是说，你喝的水就是你泡澡的水。
sat in an enclosed tub into which warm warm or cold gas was piped from below one or two even had specialist gas baths for eyes and ears where gas was injected via a small quill would you enjoy that no so they would cover you in sand that's another big another big thing um then they had these sort of communal pools and she says of these pools they were absolutely disgusting people would compare them with mulligatawny soup because they were because the spa waters were sort of you know they were strangely colored anyway but obviously you're sharing it with a load of germans a load of i mean and and british visitors too and you'd also drink the spa so you drink the same water that you'd bathe in
坐在一个封闭的浴盆里，温暖或寒冷的气体从底部输送进来，甚至有一两个专门针对眼睛和耳朵的气体浴盆，通过一根小羽毛管注入气体，你会喜欢这个吗？不，所以他们会用沙子把你盖起来，这是另一个大事，然后他们有这种公共浴池，她对这些浴池的评价是，它们绝对令人恶心，人们会把它们比作胡椒浓汤，因为温泉水有点，你知道的，颜色很奇怪，无论如何，很明显你是和一群德国人、一群我的意思是还有英国游客一起分享的，而且你还要喝温泉水，所以你喝的和洗澡的是同一缸水
so that was that was what i was homing in on that's what i know about these spas is that you the drinking is disgusting i would never do that i mean that's derented do you want a patient at barden described do you know what he compared the spa water there with? He said it tastes like the washings of a gun barrel with a dash of rotten eggs. Nice. Yeah, okay, so a whiff of sulphur. It's got to be warm. It's got to be sulphurous. It's got to have sloshed over a lot of corpulent bellies.
这就是我当时一直在琢磨的，我所了解的这些温泉疗养地就是，那里的饮用水太恶心了，我绝对不会喝，我是说，这太疯狂了。你知道巴登（Baden）的一个病人是怎么形容的吗？你知道他把那里的温泉水比作什么吗？他说，那水喝起来就像是洗过枪膛的水，还带有一点烂鸡蛋的味道。真棒。好吧，所以有一股硫磺味。它得是温的。还得带硫磺味。还得是在很多肥胖臃肿的肚子上晃荡过。
That's my sense. It has done. How about this? I'm just reading bits. This book is so infectious that I'm just reading bits out now. At Carlsbad, drinkers were even advised to wipe their teeth with stale bread or sage leaves to remove the mineral incrustation. I mean, imagine going to a spa and being told, here's some stale bread to wipe your teeth
这就是我的直觉。确实如此。这个怎么样？我只是在读一些片段。这本书太有感染力了，我忍不住把里面的片段读出来。在卡尔斯巴德（Carlsbad），甚至还建议饮水者用陈面包或鼠尾草叶子擦牙，以清除矿物质沉淀。我的意思是，想象一下你去了一个温泉疗养地，结果有人对你说，这里有些陈面包，用来擦擦你的牙齿。
after you've bathed in mulligatawny soup and had a gas injection in your eye. Do you know, the First World War, not all bad, if it put an end to that kind of nonsense so some of these places obviously are still tremendously popular so i mentioned baden davos okay but that's in switzerland so that's a mountain resort isn't it so that's slightly isn't that slightly kind of later and classier uh well i think these german resorts are often are considered very classy so they'll have the kind of casino they'll have a grand hotel and they'll she's the most famous isn't it of all
在你泡了类似于咖喱汤的澡，眼睛还注射了气体之后。你知道吗，第一次世界大战，其实也不全是坏事，如果它能终结那种无聊把戏的话。所以其中一些地方显然依然极其受欢迎，所以我提到了巴登、达沃斯，好吧，但那在瑞士，所以那是一个山地度假胜地，对吧？所以那稍微，那不是稍微有点偏后来的、更高档吗？嗯，我认为这些德国度假胜地通常被认为是非常高档的，所以它们会有那种赌场，会有大酒店，而且它是最著名的，对吧？
because obviously it's the role it plays in the second world war but they're kind of old but the sense i have of of davos is that um the idea that mountain air is good for you is a kind of later a later idea just on vichy if you're you're going to be forced to go back in time and go to any 19th century spa, Vichy is the one to go to because at Vichy they banned salad because it gave you acid and made you drink wine and eat cheese. So that's a very kind of French provincial take on the spa. Well, no wonder Petain chose it then.
因为显然它在第二次世界大战中扮演的角色，但它们有点老了。不过我对达沃斯的印象是，嗯，山里的空气对你有好处这种想法，是一种比较晚近的想法。就维希（Vichy）而言，如果你被迫时光倒流，去任何一个19th世纪的温泉疗养地，维希就是那个首选之地，因为在维希，他们禁吃沙拉，因为沙拉会产生胃酸，并让你喝红酒、吃奶酪。所以这是一种非常法国省份式的温泉体验。难怪贝当（Petain）会选择它。
Exactly. There's a bloke called Dr dr spengler and he goes to davos in the 1850s not the famous spengler the decline of the west no no a different man uh and he says gosh this seems terribly healthy and he opens his spa there and robert louis stevenson goes there in 1880 he's dying isn't he so the whole kind of consumption thing so that goes back exactly and his doctor stevenson's doctor actually seems quite a decent fellow he put him on a diet of red meat lots of wine and milk and told him to work no more than three hours a day and that sounds i mean that sounds great
没错。有个家伙叫施普林格博士（Dr. Spengler），他在1850年代去了达沃斯，不是那个著名的《西方的没落》的作者施普林格，不，不，是另一个人。嗯，他觉得，天哪，这看起来太健康了，于是他在那里开了个温泉疗养院。罗伯特·路易斯·蒂芬森（Robert Louis Stevenson）在1880年也去了那里，他当时快不行了，对吧？所以整个关于肺结核的事情，确实如此。而且史蒂芬森的医生实际上看起来是个相当不错的人，他让他遵循红肉、大量葡萄酒和牛奶的饮食方案，并告诉他每天工作不要超过三个小时，听起来，我的意思是这听起来很棒。
and and stevenson actually he hated it he went home he said uh and you know what he really objected to he objected to the scenery he said monotonous and monstrous yeah which is demented because davos you know you go for the scenery so that is an interesting point is people's people's relationship to scenery so obviously that is culturally determined because famously through the middle ages up until what is it petrock goes up a hill i goes up a mountain people are not interested in the rugged grandeur and sublime perspectives provided by the Alps. But then something changes. And I guess it's the romantic sublime, isn't it?
而且史蒂芬森其实他讨厌这个，他回家后说，呃，而且你知道他真正反对的是什么吗？他反对那里的风景。他说单调而怪异。是的，这简直疯了，因为达沃斯，你知道的，你就是为了风景而去的。所以这是一个有趣的点，就是人们与风景的关系。显然，这在文化上是决定性的。因为众所周知，从中世纪直到——是谁？彼特拉克（Petrarch）爬上一座山，我指的是爬上一座山——人们对阿尔卑斯山提供的粗犷雄伟和崇高视角并不感兴趣。但后来情况变了。我想这就是浪漫主义的崇高感，对吧？
It is the romantic sublime. And the sort of, I suppose, you have the picturesque, don't you? And we talked about that a little bit with the Grand Tour. And then the sublime, the glories of nature. And to some extent, that has never left us. Byron famously goes to Switzerland as part of his grand tour, you know, on his 1816 trip, a flight from England, where he writes, you know, Mary Shelley writes Frankenstein.
这就是浪漫主义的崇高感。还有那种，我想，你有如画般的风景，对吧？我们在谈论壮游（Grand Tour）时稍微聊过这一点。然后是崇高，大自然的壮丽。在某种程度上，这从未离开过我们。拜伦（Byron）作为他壮游的一部分，大名鼎鼎地去了瑞士，你知道的，在他1816年的旅行中，这是为了逃离英格兰，在那里他写下了——你知道的——玛丽·雪莱（Mary Shelley）写了《弗兰肯斯坦》。
Byron writes more of Childe Harold. And he is very, very upset when he is posing moodily on a mountain and a group of English tourists come up and start saying, oh, it's lovely nature. Yeah. And he goes off into a kind of massive aristocratic hissy fit about this. And that's very much a constant. What he should have done, Tom, is he should have gone to Iceland
拜伦写了更多《查尔德·哈罗德游记》。当他在山上一边摆出忧郁的姿态，一边有一群英国游客走过来开始说，“哦，大自然真可爱”时，他感到非常非常沮丧。是的。于是他为此发了一通极其严重的贵族脾气。这非常具有延续性。汤姆，他当时应该做的是，他应该去冰岛。
because that's where you really go for the glories of nature and to get away from it all. So people start going there in the mid-19th century for precisely this reason, because everywhere else has become too crowded. So just one, I know that Lucy Deathbridge writes about this, but again, I'm so sorry if we just quote, but she has this fabulous quotation from Augustus Hare
因为那里才是你真正去欣赏大自然壮丽景色并逃离尘嚣的地方。所以人们在19th世纪中期开始去那里，正是出于这个原因，因为其他所有地方都变得太拥挤了。所以就举一个例子，我知道露西·德思布里奇（Lucy Deathbridge）写过这个，但再次强调，如果我们只是引用，我深表歉意，但她有一句奥古斯都·黑尔（Augustus Hare）的精彩名言。
in 1854 on the Matterhorn. I'm very glad to have seen it, but if I can help it, nothing shall ever induce me to see it again. Oh, wow. But I often feel like that about places I've been on holiday. Don't you? You go and see something, you think, that's nice, I can help it, nothing shall ever induce me to see it again. Oh, wow. But I often feel like that about places I've been on holiday. Don't you? You go and see something you think, that's nice, I've seen it, but I'm not going to see it again.
那是1854年在马特宏峰（Matterhorn）说的。我很高兴能看到它，但如果可以的话，没有什么能诱使我再看它一眼。哦，哇。但我经常对我去度假过的地方有这种感觉。难道你不是吗？你去看了某个地方，然后你想，那挺好的，如果可以的话，没有什么能诱使我再看它一眼。哦，哇。但我经常对我去度假过的地方有这种感觉。难道你不是吗？你去看了某个地方，然后你想，那挺好的，我看过了，但我绝不会再去看它了。
Do you know, I... I mean, I felt a bit like that, a little bit like that about Disney World. I don't think I'd ever confess to myself that I felt like that about a beautiful mountain. Right. But you're probably right. Okay. Because actually, I've been to Iceland,
你知道吗，我……我的意思是，我对迪士尼世界也有点这种感觉，稍微有点这种感觉。我想我永远不会向自己承认我对一座美丽的山也有这种感觉。对的。但你可能是对的。好吧。因为事实上，我去过冰岛。
and I slightly felt that about Iceland. Did you? I think Iceland is brilliant. I mean, I'm glad to have seen it it i'm glad to have seen it but i i'm not sure i'd go there again to see it if you see what i mean well people started going to iceland i mean it's very famous because it's in a way we're going to be doing a couple of podcasts on jr r tolkien um in a few weeks aren't we and william morris's trip to iceland and his obsession with the Norse myths and with the kind of spirit of the North, that leads ultimately to Tolkien and The Hobbit and The Lord of the Rings. So no Icelandic holiday, no Amazon Prime series. Anyway, that's by the by.
我稍微对冰岛也有这种感觉。是吗？我觉得冰岛太棒了。我的意思是，我很高兴能看到它——我很高兴能看到它，但我——我不敢确定我还会再去那里看它，如果你明白我的意思的话。好吧，人们开始去冰岛，我的意思是这非常有名，因为某种程度上，我们在几周后将要做几期关于J·R·R·托尔金（J. R. R. Tolkien）的播客，对吧？还有威廉·莫里斯（William Morris）的冰岛之行，以及他对外斯神话和北方精神的迷恋，这些最终引领了托尔金、《霍比特人》以及《指环王》。所以如果没有冰岛假期，就没有亚马逊Prime剧集。无论如何，这题外话了。
But that is another trend, isn't it that again is absolutely uh a part of the contemporary travel industry that you're always looking for the next place the next the place that has been undiscovered that is isn't spoiled that um you know you go further and further afield and people were doing that in the 19th century so when people went to italy people would go and see demonstrations of pasta making where italians would be making pasta in a way that they no longer made pasta. Right. So they were just doing it to keep the tourists happy. So pasta making had become mechanized just in the same way that now if you go to, I don't know, Mexico or something in villages or Peru, people will be doing their traditional
但这是另一个趋势，对吧？这绝对也是当代旅游业的一部分，即你总是在寻找下一个地方，寻找那个尚未被发现、没有被破坏、嗯，你知道的，你越走越远，而人们在19th世纪就在这么做了。所以当人们去意大利时，人们会去看制作意大利面的演示，那里的意大利人制作意大利面的方式是他们早已不再采用的。对的。所以他们这么做只是为了让游客高兴。因此，意大利面的制作已经实现了机械化，就像现在如果你去，我不知道，比如墨西哥的某些村庄或者秘鲁，人们会展示他们的传统。
weaving. But I mean, that's not how most Mexicans and peruvians spend their time or indeed the kind of clothes they wear the classic novel and when i say novel i really mean film because i always think of it in terms of the film is um room of the view yeah of course and that's that's the so the grand tour does have a kind of longevity because all the people who are doing it's become much more feminized i think at the end of the 19th century early 20th century so young women will now go to italy and if you read particularly americans so henry james's books are all about um aristocratic well not aristocratic rich american heiress is going to daisy miller um yeah or uh they all die of malaria and things millie feel in um in the wings of the dove or something they're all they're all going to sort of venice
编织。但我的意思是，大多数墨西哥人和秘鲁人并不是这样度过时间的，这当然也不是他们穿的衣服。经典小说——当我说小说时，我其实是指电影，因为我总是从电影的角度来想它——就是《看得见风景的房间》。是的，当然。这就是——所以壮游确实具有某种长盛不衰的生命力，因为所有做这件事的人，我认为在19th世纪末、20th世纪初，它变得更加女性化了，所以年轻女性现在会去意大利，如果你读的话，尤其是美国人的作品，亨利·詹姆斯（Henry James）的书全都是关于——嗯，不是贵族，是有钱的美国女继承人去——比如《黛西·米勒》（Daisy Miller），是的，或者——她们全都死于疟疾之类的事情，比如《鸽翼》（The Wings of the Dove）里的米莉·西尔（Milly Theale）什么的，她们全都去了威尼斯。
or rome or florence are you a fan of um a room of the view the merchant ivory i haven't seen it for ages okay so it's reinforced his book absolutely one of sadie's favorite films uh merchant ivory's adaptation of em forster's Room of the View. Was it Lucy Honeychurch goes to Florence and she's accompanied by her kind of companion, isn't he? Maggie Smith, who's absolute pain, brilliant, brilliant performance. And she meets Eleanor Levish, who is a novelist with romantic dreams of Italy. And Lucy Honeychurch, a.k.a. Helena Bonham Carter.
或者是罗马，或者是佛罗伦萨。你是《看得见风景的房间》的粉丝吗，就是詹姆斯·伊沃里（Merchant Ivory）拍的那部？我好久没看过它了。好吧，所以这强化了他的书，绝对是萨迪（Sadie）最喜欢的电影之一——詹姆斯·伊沃里对E·M·福斯特（E. M. Forster）的《看得见风景的房间》的改编。是不是露西·霍尼切尔（Lucy Honeychurch）去了佛罗伦萨，陪着她的是她的某种同伴，对吧？玛吉·史密斯（Maggie Smith），绝对是个活宝，非常非常精彩的表演。然后她遇到了埃莉诺·拉维什（Eleanor Lavish），一位对意大利充满浪漫幻想的小说家。而露西·霍尼切尔，也就是海伦娜·伯翰·卡特（Helena Bonham Carter）。
A.k.a. Helena Bonham Carter. Yeah. Is rather sulkily going around with her baedica. The baedica is the German guidebook. It gives you away. The German guidebook. And Eleanor Lavish says, throw away the baedeker yeah and talks about you know what the uh the true italy is only to be found by patient observation and then um lucy
也就是海伦娜·伯翰·卡特。是的。闷闷不乐地带着她的巴德克（Baedeker）到处走。巴德克就是那本德国旅游指南。这暴露了你的身份。那本德国旅游指南。埃莉诺·拉维什说，扔掉巴德克吧。是的，并且谈论，你知道的，真正的意大利只能通过耐心的观察才能找到，然后呢，露西。
goes off and has a fling with julian sands the world's worst actor yes nature beauty i love you astonishingly good film let's hope he's not listening to this podcast, Tom. No, I think he'd accept it. That he's a bad actor. He's the worst actor ever. Is he a worse actor than Jason Connery? Yes. The second incarnation of the Hooded Man and Robin of Sherwood? Yes, he is.
离去并和朱利安·桑兹（Julian Sands）——世界上最糟糕的演员——发生了风流韵事。是的。大自然，美，我爱你。出奇地烂的一部电影。希望他没有在听这个播客，汤姆。不，我想他会接受的。承认自己是个烂演员。他是有史以来最糟糕的演员。他比杰森·康纳利（Jason Connery）更糟糕吗？是的。第二个版本的“人形连帽衫”和《罗宾汉》（Robin of Sherwood）的主演？是的，他是。
I urge you to watch Room of the View and watch him try and emote. I love you. Okay, fine. I mean, it's astonishingly bad. Worse than me. One last note on William Morris going to Iceland. I had promised you that I would tell you what'm astonishingly bad. Worse than me. One last note on William Morris going to Iceland. I had promised you
我强烈建议你去看《看得见风景的房间》，看他如何努力去表达情绪。我爱你。好吧，好吧。我的意思是，这烂得惊人。比我还糟糕。关于威廉·莫里斯去冰岛的最后一个注记。我曾答应过你，我会告诉你——烂得惊人。比我还糟糕。关于威廉·莫里斯去冰岛的最后一个注记。我曾答应过你。
that I would tell you what he thought of Iceland. He thought Iceland generally was brilliant, but he didn't like Reykjavik. He said, not a very attractive place, but better than a north country town
我会告诉你他对冰岛的看法。他觉得冰岛总体来说很棒，但他不喜欢雷克雅未克。他说，这不是一个很有吸引力的地方，但比英格兰北方的小镇要好。
in England. So that kind of thing of always having an English comparison. But, so he came back to England from Iceland and somebody said to burn jones his mate burn jones what's morris like um and uh burn jones said oh he's
所以总是会有这种英国式的比较。所以他从冰岛回到英格兰，有人问伯恩-琼斯（Burne-Jones），他的好朋友伯恩-琼斯，“莫里斯是个什么样的人，嗯？”然后伯恩-琼斯说，“哦，他太糟糕了。他回来时浑身都是生鱼的味道，嘴里谈论冰岛比以往任何时候都多。”而冰岛的人们，你知道他们对莫里斯的看法吗？他们记住他是一个到处喋喋不休地谈论他对遗嘱认证和所得税的强烈观点的人。这很奇怪，我以为他会一直在谈论那些……精灵呢，因为你知道冰岛最棒的一点是——显然不是，他当时只是在谈论他的纳税申报单。我不知道这是否是一个冰岛用来糊弄易受骗游客的故事，那就是他们在修建道路时，在法律上有义务检查这条路是否会穿过精灵居住的地方。所以你原本在一条绝对笔直的公路上开着，然后他们会绕开画一个弯，因为——精灵住在那里。所以，是的，这是一个伟大的国家，我。
awful he's come back smelling of raw fish and talking of iceland more than ever and people in iceland you know what they thought of morris they remembered him as a man who just went around talking about his strong views on probate and income tax that's odd i thought he'd be going on about all the um the elves because you know the great thing about iceland no clearly not he was just talking about his tax return i don't know whether this is a story that iceland has just held gullible tourists but that they are legally obliged when they're building a road to check that they're not going through a place where elves live so you'll be going on a perfectly straight road and then they'll kind of go around on a curve because uh there's the elves are living there so yeah it's a great country i've
听说过那个，嗯，但我认为冰岛人讲这个故事是为了，你知道的，就像我不知道，嗯，意大利人在19th世纪制作意大利面一样，他们这么做是因为他们知道游客喜欢听这个。是的，我就是这么怀疑的。我的怀疑。但如果任何来自冰岛的听众正在收听，并且能让我们知道冰岛人是否真的——你知道的——修路真的会受到路上是否有精灵的影响吗？好吧，就到这。我们完全跑题了。
heard that um but i think icelanders tell that story in order to you know in the same way that i don't know uh the italians would make pasta in the 19th century they do it because they know the tourists love to hear it yeah that's my suspicion my suspicion. But if anybody from Iceland is listening and could let us know whether people in Iceland really, you know, is road building really affected by whether elves are in the way or not? Okay, that's on. We've gone completely off piste.
我们现在完全跑题了。让我们回到假期上来。所以显然，在这整个时期，大多数人并没有去国外度假，因为他们去不起。他们买不起船票和火车票。但他们会在星期天之类的时间出去，因为有了铁路，他们可以进行一日游。
We've gone completely off piste now. Let us get back to holidays. So obviously, all this period, most people are not going on holiday abroad because they can't. They can't afford it. They can't afford the tickets to get the boat train. But they are going on Sundays and things because the railway, they can do day trips.
或者如果你在英格兰的某种纺织厂镇或工业镇工作，你可能会赶上“清仓假”（wakes week）。清仓假是指工厂老板们清洁工厂、整理所有设备，基本上是对所有设备进行维护保养的时间。所以整个镇子基本上都能放假一周。哦，对。就像学校的教职工培训日一样？就像教职工培训日，就像教职工培训周一样。是的。他们会全去海边。
Or if you work in an English sort of mill town or industrial town, you may get a wakes week. And the wakes week is when the factory owners will clean the factory and sort out all the equipment and basically service all the equipment. So you get a week off, the whole town, effectively. Oh, right. So like an inset day at school. Like an inset day, like an inset week. Yeah. And they will all go to the seaside.
我们在上一期播客中已经稍微聊过海边，比如布赖顿（Brighton）那些地方，但海边度假胜地确实是19th世纪的故事。事实上，你知道世界上第一个真正意义上的海边度假胜地——我的意思是，我们确实聊过布赖顿，但世界上第一个海边温泉度假胜地在哪吗，汤姆？温泉，我们剧透一下，它又属于德国人。
And we talked a little bit about the seaside before with Brighton and stuff in our last podcast but seaside resorts are a real 19th century story and actually do you know where the world's first true sort of seaside I mean we did talk about Brighton but the world's first seaside spa resort was Tom spa we'll give it away it was to the Germans again.
所以这个地方叫海利根达姆（Heiligendamm），位于梅克伦堡（Mecklenburg）的波罗的海海岸。这是由梅克伦堡大公于1793年建立的。我今年夏天才在波罗的海游过泳，而且非常提神醒脑。我必须这么说。你游完觉得很健康吗？你喝那里的水了吗？我喝了。
So this is a place called Heiligendamm on the Baltic coast in Mecklenburg. And this was founded in 1793 by the Grand Duke of Mecklenburg. I was swimming in the Baltic only this summer, and it was very bracing. I have to say. Did you feel healthy for it? Did you drink it? I did.
我没喝。不。虽然波罗的海不是很咸。你可以咕嘟咕嘟把它喝下去。是的，我可以建立我自己的——我自己的带有气体注射的温泉疗养院，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克的温泉，是的，快乐岛（Pleasure Island），我的快乐疗法。是的，嗯——19th世纪的德国在海滨温泉方面有很大的发展。有各种各样的岛屿。有吕根岛（Rügen），还有乌瑟多姆岛（Usedom）。有所有这些地方。
I didn't drink it. No. Although the Baltic's not very salty. You could gl plug it down drink it yeah i could set up my own um my own spa with gas injections dominic sandbrook's spa yes pleasure island my pleasure treatment yeah um so there's a big thing up in germany in 19th century germany for, for sort of seaside spas. There are all these islands. There's Rügen and there's Usedom. There are all these places.
如果你读过托马斯·曼（Thomas Mann）的书，《布登勃洛克家族》（Buddenbrooks），这是一部关于一个德国家庭的精彩小说，他们总是去特拉韦明德（Travemünde），那是吕贝克（Lübeck）附近的一个地方。事实上，即使你现在去那里，他们也有这种被称为度假建筑的特殊建筑风格，有很多漂亮的白色建筑，稍微有点木板墙的风格，但非常华丽。正如我们在这个播客里经常说的，
If you ever read Thomas Mann's book, Buddenbrook's brilliant novel, actually, about a German family, they're always going to Travermunde, which is near Lübeck. And actually, even if you go there now, they have this particular style of architecture called resort architecture, lots of lovely white buildings, sort of slightly clapperboard-ish, but very ornate. And you can imagine, we often say on this podcast,
如果你能回到过去，你会成为什么样的人？我的意思是，成为某种普鲁士将军的想法。哦，你会成为一个将军，而不是资产阶级。其实我两者都会当一点。我会成为一个退休将军，现在是个资产阶级工厂老板。是的。而且你的年纪足够大，不用去参加第一次世界大战。确切地说——而且这就引发了一个问题，嗯，我的孩子会去打第一次世界大战吗？所以这就是——事实上，你知道我的孙辈会发生什么吗？所以这现在变成了一个有点令人不安的场景，但也许我可以在另一个现实中引导德国远离战争，或者我可以做我一直想做的事，那就是缔结一个持久的英德联盟来对抗法国人。我会我的温泉度假村里这么做。也许在这个平行现实中，德皇穿对了鞋子。好吧，我们稍后会聊到德皇。所以德国人有度假胜地。还有，汤姆，美国人也有度假胜地。所以你知道第一个美国度假胜地的名字吗？不知道。看，这太丢脸了，因为首先——你知道第一个美国度假胜地的名字吗？不知道。看，这太丢脸了，因为我实际上在这个节目之前的笔记里发给你了。
if you could go back in time, what would you be? I mean, the idea of being a sort of Prussian general. Oh, you'd be a general, not a bourgeois. I'd be a bit of both, actually. I'd be a retired general who's now a bourgeois factory owner. Yes. And you'd be old enough not to have to fight in the in the first world war precise well and that that raises the issue of um would my children be fighting the first world war so that's and actually you know
我在听众面前拉开了帷幕。所以他们看到了制作这个播客的全部恐怖之处。这是一个叫新泽西州梅代（Cape May）的地方。梅代。代。不，梅代听起来显然是一个人的名字。我本来要说梅代听起来像是个女演员的名字。是的。
what's going to happen to my grandchildren so it's becoming a bit of a troubling scenario now but maybe i can in an alternative reality i can coax germany away or maybe i can do the thing i've always wanted to do which is to strike a lasting ang Anglo-German alliance against the French. And I'll do that in my spa resort. Maybe in this alternate reality, the Kaiser does wear the right shoes. Well, we'll be coming to the Kaiser a little bit later. So the Germans have resorts. Also, Tom, the Americans have resorts. So you know the name of the first American resort? No. See, this is shameful because first the name of the first American resort? No. See, this is shameful because I actually sent it to you in the notes before this episode.
它是凯特。凯特·梅（Kate May）可能是特蕾莎·梅（Theresa May）的亲戚。无论如何，听着，这就是梅代，它在新泽西州。你最初可以从费城坐驿马车去那里。但后来人们在1812年战争之后开始乘汽船去那里。那里有寄宿公寓、酒店和所有这些设施。而且梅代至今在很大程度上一直在衰落，我相信，因为基本上没有人再去新泽西州度假了。
I've drawn back the curtain there for the listeners. So they they see the full horror of making this podcast. It's a place called Cape May in New Jersey. Cape May. Cape. No, Cape May sounds like it's clearly a person. I was going to say Cape May sounds like a kind of actress. Yeah.
但它仍然以“美国第一个海滨度假胜地”的身份在做宣传。我想去。好吧，你应该去。我真的很想去。是的，我想去新泽西州，走一走《黑道家族》（The Sopranos）的足迹，这样我就可以——亚伯拉罕·林肯（Abraham Lincoln）去过梅代，所以——好吧，他配得上亚伯拉罕，诚实的亚伯，没错。不过，亚伯拉罕·林肯没有去过佛罗伦萨，而佛罗伦萨是最大的海滨故事，显而易见——所以那是建立者是一个叫亨利·弗格勒（Henry Flagler）的人，他是个标准石油公司（Standard Oil）的
It's Kate. Kate May could be a relative of Theresa May. Anyway, listen, it's Cape May, and it's in New Jersey. And you can go there initially from Philadelphia on a stagecoach. But then people start going after the War of 1812 in steamboats. And they have boarding houses and hotels and all these kinds of things. And Cape May still very much has been in decline, I believe, because basically nobody goes to New Jersey on holiday anymore.
大亨，他在佛罗伦萨修建了铁路。他基本上创建了——他创建的第一个地方是他们——我相信他们把圣奥古斯丁（St. Augustine）发音为一个大型度假胜地，然后是迈阿密、棕榈滩和所有这些地方。而且，你知道的——加利福尼亚是什么时候变成一个——嗯，加利福尼亚，我不认为加利福尼亚变成了一个吸引人的地方。加利福尼亚太远了，不是吗？我的意思是——嗯，如果你在加利福尼亚就不远了。嗯，加利福尼亚，我不认为加利福尼亚变成了一个吸引人的地方。加利福尼亚太远了，不是吗？
But it still trades as America's first seaside resort. I'd like to go. Well, you should. I'd really like to go. Yeah, I'd like to go to new jersey and do the sopranos trail so i could okay abraham lincoln went to cape may so well he's good enough for abe honest abe exactly abraham lincoln did not however go to florida and florida is the big seaside story obviously so that was set up by a man called henry flagler who was a standard oil
我的意思是……嗯，如果你在加利福尼亚就不远了。不，显然，我的意思是，如果人们在加利福尼亚，他们就会去海滩。但是，我的意思是，美国东海岸的人们正前往，你知道的，去……如果他们不去新泽西州，他们就会坐着亨利·弗格勒的铁路去佛罗伦萨。加利福尼亚所有那些著名的海滩是什么时候开始被开发的？这是一个非常好的问题。我其实不知道答案。
baron and he built railroads in Florida. And he basically created, the first place he created was what they, I believe they pronounce St. Augustine as a sort of big resort, and then Miami and Palm Beach and all these kinds of places. And, you know- And when is California becoming a- Well, California, I don't think California becomes an attraction. California is too far, isn't it? I mean- Well, not if you're in California. Well, California, I don't think California becomes an attraction. California's too far, isn't it?
我会有兴趣知道，也许我们的听众可以，因为显然加利福尼亚海滩的鼎盛时期感觉确实是在50年代和60年代，对吧？是的。但人们在那之前肯定就已经去海滩了。不过说到海滩，既然我们是英国人，汤姆，如果我们不提那个最迷人的度假胜地，那就太失职了。
I mean... Well, not if you're in California. No, obviously, I mean, people are going to the beach if they're in California. But, I mean, East Coast Americans are going, you know, to... If they're not going to New Jersey, they're going to Florida on Henry Flagler's railroads. When is, I don't know, all the famous beaches in California, when are they starting to be colonized? That's a very good question. I don't actually know the answer.
伟大的布莱克浦（Blackpool）镇。所以布莱克浦在铁路到来之前什么都不是。因此，在18th世纪末，有一辆从曼彻斯特和哈利法克斯开往布莱克浦的驿马车。但随后在1846年修建了一条支线铁路，接着布莱克浦就腾飞了，所以人们去过这些清仓假，他们基本上有一周假期离开纺织厂，因为工厂要重新安装所有设备，所以他们只是——整个镇子基本上都会坐上火车。
I'd be interested, maybe our listeners can, because obviously the heyday of Californian beaches really feels like the 50s and 60s, doesn't it? Yeah. But people must have been going to the beach before that. But talking of beaches, since we are British, Tom, it would be remiss of us not to mention the most glamorous resort of all,
蜂拥来到布莱克浦度过这一周，只是骑骑驴，嘲笑音乐喜剧演员，他们修建了码头，布莱克浦是一个真正的潮流——我的意思是，现在英国很多人的冲动是嘲笑布莱克浦，但他们是世界上第一个拥有全电力供应的小镇，嗯，他们有电动街头照明，他们有彩灯，这再次有点像拉斯维加斯，它为拉斯维加斯开辟了道路。哦。布莱克浦拥有世界上第一条有轨电车线路。它拥有最大的——当布莱克浦塔在1890年代建造时，我想是1894年，它是整个大英帝国最大、最高的建筑。
the great town of Blackpool. So Blackpool was nothing before the arrival of the railways. So there was a stagecoach from Manchester and Halifax to Blackpool in the late 18th century. But then there's a branch line that is built in 1846, and then Blackpool just goes through the roof so people go on these wakes weeks they're basically at the week off from the mill because they're refitting all the equipment so they just the whole town will basically get on the train
他们有游乐海滩（Pleasure Beach），他们在1907年拥有了英国第一座木制过山车。布莱克浦每年吸引数百万游客，所以那些——你知道的——工人阶级游客，以前由于清仓假之类的原因、由于更具家长式作风的雇主等原因而被排除在假期之外的人——我的意思是他们仍然没有法定的休假权——但他们却以绝对庞大的数量涌向那里。好吧，我明年要去布莱克浦，是的，去度假，所以我和我的朋友杰米，我们——去年我们——我们做了一件事，就是我们径直穿过了英国，明年我们要从萨福克（Suffolk）径直走到布莱克浦，所以我们最后会到达布莱克浦，所以我很期待。你最近去过布莱克浦吗？我从未去过布莱克浦。你看，我去过布莱克浦，虽然萨迪是在那里出生的。是吗？我在布莱克浦拍过戏，我们可能有一些来自布莱克浦的听众，所以我说话很谨慎。说实话，这可能不是我度假目的地的首选。好吧，我很期待。我会有兴趣听听你对它的看法。
and pile into blackpool for the week and just ride donkeys and laugh at musical comedians and they build piers and they the blackpool is is a real trend i mean now the temptation for a lot of people in britain is to laugh at blackpool but they are the they're the first town in the world to have all electric power um they have electric street lighting they have the illuminations again it's kind of vegas it's it's blazing a path for vegas oh. Blackpool has the world's first electric tramway. It has the largest, when the Blackpool Tower was built in the 1890s, I think it's 1894, it is the largest, the tallest building in the entire British Empire.
希望你能够与听众分享你的看法。我们的制作人多米尼克在聊天里发了一条便签，上面写着：布莱克浦的游乐海滩，最初的快乐岛？所以游乐海滩建于1896年，多米尼克，这是一个了不起的游乐园，非常非常受欢迎，这也是那么多人去那里的原因之一。但是，汤姆，我们几乎已经到达第一次世界大战了，不是吗？是的。
They have the Pleasure Beach, and they have the first wooden roller coaster in Britain in 1907. And Blackpool is getting millions of visitors a year so people who are you know working class visitors people who have previously been shut out of holidays because of things like wakes weeks because of more paternalistic employers and things i mean they still have no statutory right to a holiday but they're going in absolutely colossal numbers well i will be going next year to blackpool yeah on holiday so my friend jamie and i we uh last last year we um we did this thing where we just went in a straight
第一次世界大战开始时，许多人正在度假。所以德皇，在很大程度上可以说是《历史的剩余部分》的朋友，虽然有点不太可能，但他是这个播客的常驻客串明星。在导致第一次世界大战爆发的七月危机期间，他大部分时间都在度假，这在我看来，总是完全粉碎了“德皇怀有某种阴险意图……”的想法。他当时不是在度假吗，是在哪里，挪威？他是的，他在峡湾。他在挪威，因为我想我看到过某种他坐过的奇怪椅子。德皇的椅子。
line across britain and next year we're going to go from suffolk to blackpool in a kind of straight line so we're going to end up in blackpool so looking forward have you been to blackpool recently i've never been to blackpool see i have been to blackpool although sadie was born there was she and i filmed in blackpool um we may have listeners from blackpool. Although Sadie was born there. Was she? And? I filmed in Blackpool. We may have listeners from Blackpool, so I'm weighing my words carefully. It's probably not the top of my list of holiday destinations, to be quite honest with you. Well, I'm looking forward to it. I should be interested to hear what you make of it.
德皇的椅子。我想当斐迪南大公遇刺的消息传给他时，他正坐在那把椅子上。不，事情发生时他在柏林。但也许有什么消息传给了他。那是我想象出来的。不过当我们滑向战争时，英国正在度假。所以有一个银行假期，即8月3日星期一。很多人在玩。
Hopefully, you'll be able to share your views with the listeners. Dom, our producer, is putting a note in the chat that says, Pleasure Beach in Blackpool, the original Pleasure Island? So the Pleasure Beach was built in 1896, Dom, and this tremendous amusement park and very, very popular, part of the reason why so many people went. But, Tom, we've almost reached the First World War, haven't we? We have.
这是英格兰最古老的板球节，汤姆。坎特伯雷板球周（Canterbury Cricket Week）。我不知道那是什么。我的意思是，典型的欧洲大陆阴谋，对吧？在板球节期间挑起战争，所以萨里队正在奥瓦尔球场（Oval）对阵诺丁汉郡队，观众人山人海，嗯，温莎和伊顿赛艇会。再也没有这样的纯真了。是的，好吧，我认为我们应该以那首菲利普·拉金（Philip Larkin）的诗结束，因为这是——这是8月3日的银行假期——前一天。
The First World War began with a lot of people on holiday. So the Kaiser, very much a friend of the rest is history, slightly implausibly, a regular guest star on this podcast. He was on holiday for much of the July crisis running up to the outbreak of the First World War, which to me always sort of completely gives the lie to the idea that the Kaiser had in a sinister... Was he not on holiday in, was it Norway? He was, he was in the fjords. He was in Norway, because I think I have seen there was some kind of weird chair he had. The Kaiser's chair.
晚上，德皇向比利时发出了最后通牒，称我们要自由通行。比利时人显然会进行抵抗。所以基本上，英国正在度假。但在威斯敏斯特，政治家们正在开会，就在第二天，德国入侵了比利时，英国对德国宣战。伴随着这一切，汤姆，《历史的剩余部分》播客的这一集必须结束了。不过我们要以那首拉金的诗结束吗？为什么不呢？既然这完全是关于假期的。好吧，不仅如此，我们录制这期节目正值菲利普·拉金诞辰100周年纪念日。所以这似乎是一个完全恰当的致敬。
The Kaiser's chair. And I think he was sitting in it when the news brought to him of the assassination of Franz Ferdinand. No, he was in Berlin when that happened. But maybe some news was brought to him. I'm imagining it then. But Britain is on holiday as we slide into war. So there's a bank holiday, Monday the 3rd of August. Lots of people are playing.
我把它摆在面前。这一次，我将用我自己的声音来读它，而不是用某种荒谬的其他声音。我们开始吧。菲利普·拉金的《1914》：那些长长的不整齐的队伍，耐心地站着，就像它们在奥瓦尔球场或维拉公园球场外排成长队一样，帽子的帽顶，阳光照在长满胡须的古老面孔上，咧着嘴笑，仿佛这一切都只是八月银行假期的玩笑，关闭的店铺，遮阳篷上褪色的老字号名称，法寻硬币和金币，以及穿着深色衣服玩耍的孩子们，他们的名字是以国王和王后的名字命名的，印着可可和烟草卷的铁皮广告牌，以及整天敞开大门的酒馆。而乡村毫不在意，地名全都被盛开的野草笼罩在一片朦胧中，
It's the oldest cricket festival in England, Tom. The Canterbury Cricket Week. I don't know what that is. I mean, typical continental plot, isn't it? To start a war when the cricket festival's on so surrey are playing nottinghamshire at the oval massive crowds uh the windsor and eton regatta never such innocence again yeah well i think we should end with that larkin poem because it's the it's the bank holiday the third of august um the previous
田野在小麦不安的寂静下投射出末日般的阴影。穿着不同制服的仆人们，在巨大宅邸里拥有狭小的房间，轿车扬起的尘土。从未有过如此纯真，在此之前或之后，都未曾不发一言地滑入过去。男人们把花园收拾得整整齐齐，数以千计的婚姻又多维持了一小会儿。再也没有这样的纯真了。再见。再见。
night the kaiser has sent an ultimatum to Belgium, saying we want free passage. The Belgians are clearly going to resist. So basically, Britain is on holiday. But in Westminster, the politicians are meeting, and it's the very next day that Germany invaded Belgium
感谢收听《历史的剩余部分》。想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的剩余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论的必听节目。
and Britain declared war on Germany. And with that, Tom, the podcast, this episode of The Rest Is History must come to an end. But shall we end with that Larkin poem? Why not? Since it's all about holidays. Well, not only that, but we are recording this on the 100th anniversary of Philip Larkin's birthday. So it seems an entirely fitting tribute.
还有海量的八卦花絮，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。
I have it in front of me. And for once, I will read it in my own voice rather than a ludicrous other voice. Here we go. 1914 by Philipilip larkin those long uneven lines standing as patiently as if they were stretched outside the oval or villa park the crowns of hats the sun on mustached archaic faces grinning as if it were all an august bank holiday lark and shut shops, the bleached established names on the sun blinds, the farthings and sovereigns and dark clothed children at play called after kings and queens, the tin advertisements for cocoa and twist and the pubs wide open all day. And the countryside not caring, the place names all hazed over with flowering grasses
如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
and fields shadowing doomsday lines under wheat's restless silence. The differently dressed servants with tiny rooms in huge houses, the dust behind limousines. Never such innocence, never before or since, has changed itself to past without a word. The men leaving the gardens tidy, the thousands of marriages lasting a little while longer. Never such innocence again. Goodbye. Bye-bye.
田野在小麦不安的寂静下勾勒出末日的轮廓。穿着不同制服的仆人们住在庞大宅邸里的小房间里，豪车扬起阵阵尘埃。从未有过如此纯真的时刻，无论是从前还是以后，都在一言不发中成为了过去。男人们把花园收拾得井井有条，数千桩婚姻又多维持了一会儿。再也没有这样的纯真了。再见。再见。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要收听独家番外、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们联袂主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》，这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻与评论
splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club
精彩的娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将为娱乐产业揭开神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部
if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您想要无广告收听、独家番外以及优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。